cet été la série événement arrive sur
cold moustache intro les familles prêtes
à tout pour se le procurer
je parle bien évidemment de la série
ah non non mais je parlais pas de ça oui
oui je connais la série à laquelle vous
pensez à un petit peu surcoté à mon goût
mais oui je vois très bien je vois très
bien sûr je dis pas que j'aime pas un
mais mais voilà quoi bref je parle de la
série le trône des frogs le trône de fer
ben moi j'ai envie de vous dire pourquoi
pas on est une des maisons les plus
anciennes du royaume notre maître
d'armes
c'est un descendant des chevaucheurs de
dragon du continent disparu de notre
grande expérience
nous pensons que nous sommes les dignes
héritiers du trône de fer sur papier ses
beaux châteaux quoi nous sommes les
frogs être une femme lettrée entouré de
sauvages sans éducation c'est pas le
plus dur dans ce cas le problème c'est
plus les tentatives de viols pendant
l'hiver tout de suite senti que j'étais
pas chaud mon épouse avait ou le dit
comment va recruter frères d'offres en
bougies parfumées
j'ai trouvé que ça arrivait à arriver
est ce qu'on pourrait pas égaler l'hiver
ils ont trouvé une solution pour un prix
marcheurs blanc après pour moi ça reste
des clubs alors la bonne nouvelle c'est
que pour les tuer faut les plantes et ça
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'on n'a
aucune idée de ce que c'est je me casse